[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia
joe biden es el primer presidente de los
eeuu en reconocer con la palabra
genocidio a la matanza de 1.500.000
armenios entre 1915 y 1923 el
reconocimiento de bailén provocó el
rechazo inmediato del presidente turco
recep tayyip erdogán quien continúa
negando el exterminio de los armenios el
segundo genocidio más estudiado después
del holocausto judío desde la toma de
constantinopla en 1453 el imperio
otomano se alzó victorioso en la región
de medio oriente el norte de áfrica y el
este de europa varios pueblos milenarios
y autóctonos de dichos territorios
cayeron bajo la influencia del imperio
uno de esos pueblos fue el de los
armenios de mayoría cristiana ortodoxa
asentado en el cáucaso y el este de
anatolia su gente sufrió la opresión
religiosa de los musulmanes turcos y
kurdos
sus casas no podían ser más altas que
las de ellos les fue prohibido el uso de
armas caballos y camellos y no podían
sonar las campanas de las iglesias pues
competiría con el llamado a la oración
de las mezquitas en síntesis los
armenios fueron ciudadanos de segunda
clase en los cerca de 600 años de
hegemonía del imperio otomano pero a
comienzos del siglo 20 los otomanos
estaban en decadencia y al imperio se le
conocía como el hombre o el viejo
enfermo de europa el 28 de julio de 1914
tras el asesinato del archiduque
francisco fernando de austria en
sarajevo estalló la primera guerra
mundial se trató de un conflicto que
opuso a las principales potencias de la
época de un lado la triple alianza
contaba al imperio alemán el imperio
austrohúngaro y el imperio otomano del
otro lado la triple entente que incluía
a francia reino unido y el imperio ruso
los rusos derrotaron al imperio otomano
en las batallas libradas en los frentes
del
el ministro de guerra otomano en verdad
culpó directamente a los armenios de la
derrota al acusarlos de haber conspirado
y ayudado directamente a los ejércitos
del zar el 24 de abril de 1915 el
gobierno otomano de los jóvenes turcos
capturó a cerca de 250 intelectuales y
líderes armenios que vivían en
constantinopla actual estambul como una
campaña de propaganda para presentar a
la minoría étnica armenia como una
amenaza para la seguridad del imperio la
gran mayoría de estas 250 personas
fueron gradualmente deportadas y
asesinadas por los turcos una muestra de
lo que ocurriría a cientos de miles de
armenios en los años venideros el 29 de
mayo de 1915 el gobierno de turno del
imperio otomano que era el de los
jóvenes turcos aprobó la ley de
deportaciones con la cual se podía
desterrar a cualquier persona que
representase una amenaza para la
seguridad nacional una legislación
dio luz verde al ejército de los
otomanos para deliberadamente deportar a
los armenios del cáucaso hacia el
inclemente desierto del norte de siria
las marchas de la muerte fueron
travesías forzadas de miles de armenios
por el desierto circundante de deir ezor
las autoridades militares retuvieron los
suministros con que alimentar estas
procesiones de manera que miles de
armenios comenzaron a morir de inanición
the new york times reportó en agosto de
1915 que los márgenes del éufrates al
noreste de siria estaban llenos de
cadáveres como resultado de un plan para
exterminar de hambre a todo el pueblo
armenio
mientras las caravanas de armenios
avanzaban hacia una muerte segura en el
desierto los turcos aprovecharon para
decomisar y expropiar sus títulos de
propiedad y tomar posesión de sus
distritos la violación fue otro de los
flagelos del genocidio de acuerdo con
válter rösler cónsul alemán en la ciudad
de alepo para la época
cuarta parte de las mujeres que eran
jóvenes y de agradable apariencia fueron
violadas sistemáticamente por los
militares turcos otomanos los armenios
que sobrevivieron a las marchas de la
muerte fueron eliminados en más de una
veintena de campos de concentración
instalados en la actual frontera de
turquía con siria e irak
eitán belkin un oficial judío infiltrado
en el ejército otomano reportó haber
visto la quema de 5000 armenios como
parte del esquema de masacres que
incluía quemas masivas ahogamientos
envenenamientos y sobredosis de drogas
el genocidio armenio ocupó gran parte de
la primera guerra mundial desde 1915
hasta 1918 pero prosiguió hasta 1923
durante estos años se disolvió por
completo el imperio otomano y la
comunidad internacional reconoció la
soberanía de la recién creada república
de turquía turquía niega de plano que se
llame genocidio a la matanza de armenios
y aunque hubo masacres en su contra no
existió un plan de exterminarlos
sin embargo múltiples misiones
diplomáticas recién ocurridas la
diáspora armenia y numerosas
investigaciones del mundo académico
internacional confirmaron con hechos y
testimonios que sí lo fue actualmente
alrededor de 30 países el primero de
ellos uruguay y entre los que se cuentan
eeuu francia y alemania- reconocen que
si existió un genocidio 106 años después
de que hubiese comenzado este genocidio
en el que murieron cerca de un millón
quinientos mil armenios las relaciones
entre turquía y armenia permanecen
tensas y beligerantes una enemistad que
data de siglos atrás así concluimos soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]